hey i'm jimmy oyang and i play josh lynn
hi my name is darren barnett and i play
tag hi i'm nina dobrev and i play
natalie in love hard and we're about to
play buzzfeed's which holiday couple are
you
the first question is first things first
what is your love language
you guys know the love languages yeah
yeah yeah i have heard of them and i
definitely know mine so it's words of
affirmation quality time physical touch
acts of service gifts something only you
and your partner share is it a love
language you like to receive or the love
language you like to give usually
whatever you like to receive naturally
we also do that
very nice nina that's why you're in such
a great relationship uh mine is active
service that's me i love to cook for
people i love to do this do that and i i
love it when other people do that for me
actually jimmy i am a hundred percent
physical touch i am a touch guy i really
like
cuddling and holding hands and you know
all of that i uh
i love someone i'm hugging him all the
time all right next question pick a
controversial holiday movie to watch
with your significant other die hard
mean girl harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone carol frozen or edward
scissorhands wow huh
we talked about this i thought frozen
was a christmas movie you guys said it's
not
that might be the most controversial i i
guess it is i'm going to because it
happens in the snow don't don't mean
that it's a christmas movie well that
and mean girls because mean girls like
there's there's a one scene where
they're
in an outfit so some people say it's a
christmas movie but it absolutely
not i gotta be honest i mean just with
these movies i would watch mean girls
i it's it's a happy movie puts me in a
good mood i'm gonna go with mean girls
i'm gonna second that i did frozen you
know i'm just that type of dude all
right next question is which holiday
themed beverage are you sipping on by
the open fire
options are peppermint hot cocoa a hot
toddy
a very moscow mule a mold wine some
eggnog or some champagne i've never had
like a legit eggnog i gotta just be
basic and pick champagne because the
fire's already hot you want something
like crisp i'm going with a hot teddy i
had one for the first time last year and
it was delightful i'm with you on that
one i'm i'm a big hot toddy girl
especially when you're in a cabin or on
the mountain somewhere and you want to
have a little spiked warm treat to warm
you up from being outside in the cold
hot tub
choose a holiday tune to sing during
karaoke maybe it's cold outside natalie
and josh remix ooh that's an instant
classic all i want for christmas by
mariah carey merry christmas happy
holidays by nsync last christmas by
william let it snow by dean martin and
it's beginning to look a lot like
christmas by johnny mathis
i love last christmas i mean that's my
jam but natalie and josh remix maybe
it's cold outside we got we have to go
with that i agree we're very biased
though
as much as i love it i can't deny dean
martin i love being one i'm gonna go
with let it snow i ain't even mad at
that you know i'm taking second place
dee martin i'm okay the next question
pick a fun date night activity candle
making class just like what we do in the
movie or what i do in the movie mini
golf
paint and sip
and intimate dinner a concert a nice
long walk i'm gonna go with a nice long
walk there's just
kind of no expectation um you can kind
of go where the wind takes you and
there's great conversations to be had on
a nice long walk depends what location
you're at if you're in the east coast
that might be very cold i agree with you
darren i like conversation but i also
like food and i love booze i'm gonna
have to go with the intimate dinner yeah
my go-to is definitely an intimate
dinner you know even with us cooking
together but i think just something fun
i would pick paint and sip or candle
making class um you know what actually
for this movie i learned how to make
candles like it's very easy and it's
very cool and nice uh something cute i i
would go with candle making class quick
your significant other is in the
bathroom and you have time to check one
app which is it twitter instagram tick
tock facebook snapchat or myfitnesspal
wow this is scandalous man why you gotta
check when they're gone i know right i'm
thinking about that too if they were in
the room you'd be engaged with them and
talking oh okay you're not just checking
dms i hope not okay i gotta go with
instagram i mean that that's the one my
favorite goes to first yeah that's
pretty much all i use so yeah but if
they have an option for like uh my yahoo
fantasy football app i'll do that last
but not least choose a quote from an
iconic holiday movie to me no i can't do
it darren you do it do the british
accent to me you are perfect
love actually oh
okay you sound like the oscar presenter
you have a pretty face you should be on
a christmas card
elf it's christmas eve
and we are going to go celebrate being
young and being alive the holiday just
because you can't see something doesn't
mean it doesn't exist santa claus
remember george no man is a failure who
has friends it's a wonderful life
yippee cayenne [ __ ] die hard i
gotta say the it's a wonderful lifeline
just beautiful the santa claus was one
of my favorite movies growing up it's a
great message just because you can't see
something doesn't mean it doesn't exist
because you can't really see love can
you that's really deep darren my
favorite quote has got to be to me
you are perfect it makes me cry every
single time you said that
i am myself it's natalie and josh from
love heart baby oh my god i got the same
one i got jack and sally from the
nightmare before christmas that's
hilarious
that's so funny it says to you love
doesn't always have to be bright lights
and fireworks sometimes a tender budding
friendship is the best way for any love
to blossom i'll get by
you got natalie and josh to you the true
meaning of love isn't someone with the
perfect dating profile but it's that
special someone who makes you feel
perfect despite your imperfections oh
that's very nice i don't know if i want
tim burton directing my love story but
i'll take it thank you buzzfeed thank
you for playing with us and i hope you
love the holiday couple that you got and
catch us all of us on netflix's love
heart
you